something has to change uh when it comes
to
border immigration we're urging
president button
to create a special position to bring
order to chaos
put somebody in charge whose focus is
just on the border
and that's jay johnson democrat
congressman cuellar and republican
senator graham
pleading for the biden administration to
take real action
at the border and tap jay johnson as the
new borders are
this is vice president harris announces
a trip to asia
despite the crisis at the border
intensifying here to react is former
acting dhs secretary
ken cuccinelli ken you really got a feel
for henry crayo the representative
um there in texas i mean he sounds so
desperate he's so upset
um that no one is desperate yeah i mean
no one in the administration seems to
care
what's happening to his constituents to
the people there in texas
um senator graham saying you know the
answer might be jay johnson what do you
think
well look jay johnson has broad
bipartisan respect
for for his performance as secretary of
homeland security
he was the person who gave us the
benchmark of a thousand a day is a
crisis coming over the border and they
are at
six times that wow at the border they're
completely overwhelmed
and look i give these two gentlemen all
the credit in the world on the
republican side
senator graham is often in the
bipartisan mix on immigration issues so
he isn't always the toughest to have him
and then a democrat henry cuellar
calling this
out first of all is an incredible vote
of no
confidence in mayorkas the current
secretary and
vice president harris who is essentially
filling the role they're describing for
jay johnson
that's incredible i mean you know the
politics of this you've been there
um you know you you saw what it was like
before you see what it's
happening now just be honest and tell us
what is
is this deliberate
yes yes so that was what i was going to
say these two gentlemen
i give them a lot of credit for optimism
with respect to the notion that this
administration
actually wants to solve the problem
interestingly enough
the greatest inconvenience for the
administration is the covid19
right because they just want to ship
illegals in here right
this is about processing them in look at
how they deal with covet 19 everywhere
else in the country everywhere else it's
a hazmat emergency
but they don't give a rat's tail on the
border right so
it's so i want you to listen to this um
the sound from dr rashel welinski down
playing
uh covet at the at the border right
do you know the surge how the surge of
illegal immigrants with covet is
affecting the overall
rate you know it sounds like the
percentages down there on the border are
astronomical
yeah you know i would say that the
percentages in the southern part of this
country are really quite high
and i don't necessarily think we can
attribute all of that to what's going on
at the southern border
notice how she skirts that fauchi did
the same thing they asked him you know
earlier in the year
when we had that variant coming in from
brazil and he says well i don't that's
too political i don't want to get
involved
in that but he doesn't mind getting
involved with coping restrictions for
for americans all over the country right
so look when you don't get an answer to
a question like that
that's an admission that it's a terrible
problem in that region and it is a
terrible problem in that region and look
a lot of
a lot of this we talk about this like
public health but so much of it is math
and when you think back to the beginning
of the delta variant
that was when it was most important to
be keeping
out uh to not have an open borders
policy
yeah um now we're there it's still the
worst part of the country
and they won't shut it down they won't
even slow it down this is terrible for
american security
and public health yeah it's a crazy time
um you know as we're trying to get out
of this pandemic to have an open
southern border policy
ken cuccinelli thank you so much for
joining us this morning
good to be with you all right up